[Music]
in panty snatcher news why do people do
that that's the Japanese by Raymond
airing a college student was arrested
for stealing $2,000 worth of a woman's
underwear well there's a lot our girls
underwear expenses late which is a one
average they'd like for a secret
Victoria Secrets more expensive you go
to Target for underwear you get him for
five bucks yeah let's see look Alex but
we could get like eight boxers for like
$20 so $40 for a set and no one cares
what we were exactly he only thought
underwear by the way not bras Oh not bra
okay I got do the math again
how much are underwear like 15 bucks a
hundred and thirty three pairs of thongs
granny panties question underwear are
thongs more expensive than underwear
they're less fabric uh-oh
let's have it but you don't the
engineering is has to be higher quality
oh oh to resist the ass [ __ ] right it
has to be strong enough but you have
less fabric to do it in so actually
engineering wise it's much more
complicated but sometimes Emily all that
lay since they're like how does it all
stay together glue men's will pout now
he's wishing there's five wizards out
there all praying every day the thong
lizard it stays together that it falls
apart
no that that it stays intact so what
happened here so there was this
notorious underwear thief attacking
female students and you it's my alma
mater yeah you went there yeah so this
guy he was a courser student here and
you you see San Diego I have been I have
left San Diego for over a decade now
okay oh oh it wasn't me did he get fresh
panties that were like nicely was read
the story
you fight a guess I would say dirty
O'Hare well actually I don't know so
you're filling it from the laundry room
oh I don't know if he was feeling it
like when they first put them in and
they're dirty or like after they're in
the dryer regardless they're not brand
new just to let you guys know a girl's
[ __ ] is something very disgusting
sometimes like discharge and stuff
that's why they have like women's pad
Justin you know did you think that's not
for the discharge is cleaning itself out
no but I'm saying like it's not like
that porn star [ __ ] we're just nothing
ever comes out you know what I mean
like I think like there's just a little
bit misconception that guys have when it
comes to Oh Janice I like yeah I think I
understand the fresh laundry panties
because fresh laundry clothes is just
awesome and it has a smell the person
yeah yeah even even fresh clothes
you can smell like every individual like
you go oh yeah you never smell that when
you ball someone's sweater but that's
not yeah it's like you put it on in your
life it's the detergent yep I never
notice underwear guy or girl even if
it's fresh out fresh out the laundry I
would not put my face in it you're not
Japanese
yeah I think I think woman's woman's
underwear is privily fine just on the
woman and that's where it should be like
it off but that's my yeah he likes to
struggle yeah he likes to move it to the
side it was his idea he draws the
outline i discarded
you see he's not objecting okay yeah so
so weeks before this guy got arrested
because they did arrest him his name is
David chow
that sounds Chinese to me Wow I never
know that Chinese before evolving dude I
think they meant to Michael choose his
parents they even had signs in the
laundry rooms letting people know like
hey there's someone going around
stealing women's underwear
there was this one student that claimed
that she lost like an entire washing
machine load where it was one shirt and
10 to 14 under pairs of underwear hey if
she's got a lot of she waits a long time
different laundry yeah what do you know
she's literally waiting for the granny
panty like like the bottom of the drawer
oh yeah of course she watches yeah I
have 30 boxers
what was their picture him there was
none how'd they catch him though you
know what was it a stink be careful when
finally there was another student that
she noticed that he was carrying a
laundry basket that had her under a
[ __ ] that's my phone yeah so then this
girl she thought she stayed behind and
she followed him all the way to his dorm
and then that's when she confronted
confronted the guy that's my panties
[ __ ] caught he or she also
called the police and notified that that
was the underwear thief if she does he
kicked out I know that he get expelled
that sucks dummy I don't I love so what
is he doing with it that's my question
she's all be smelling it and jacking off
he was probably jacking off he was
actually wearing them no hearing them
okay so I don't I don't judge anyone's
personal preferences but I do what is
the sensation of why guys want to do
that I don't know because
when I was a kid with my mom's mom came
scholars know but a song though we have
[ __ ] balls that like flop like what
comes under laughs you won't even though
you would've thought heart only goes on
your butt so that's from your butthole
perversion like why do some people like
to have like PI stone in their face and
they come to that [ __ ] I don't [ __ ]
know
there's some weird type of perversion
but you know if you guys ever well some
of you guys who haven't gone to college
but if you stay in a dorm room there
will be a lot of weird people that's
true yeah like I could name already like
two or three people off the top of my
head in my first year in the dorm that
remind me of this [ __ ] right
here cuz it's like I feel like you sit
like the fabric cuz then you don't need
to wear it you could just have fabric
maybe they're wearing it for them that
turns them on maybe he's like his her
pussy's on my balls
oh yeah there was a guy in the I might
have said this already but there's a
dude that was he had a BB gun and he was
hunting rabbits and [ __ ] and on
Riverside just then he was just giving
them and eating them oh my god he likes
natural food well he also made a
homemade bomb in the closet and cops
came no he was Asian guy oh I don't know
I did talk the Freak this panty fetish
thing to me it's such a pathetic fetish
it's almost like digging in the garbage
can like you know it's kind of like oh
let me let me just cut a little lock of
her hair so I could jack off to it later
weird like like oh let me [ __ ]
collect her urine so I could [ __ ]
pour it on my body not even like
voyeuristic in the sense of like you can
actually see the person it's like it's
like a piece of them yeah yeah and
they're like so so low like they they
have such a low self-esteem it's like
let me get the [ __ ] dust from her
shoes like a jack off to their offending
we were potentially offending a lot of
people I think it's okay to have a
fetish I think it's when you have to
sneak around and steal and like yeah
it's rapey that's why that's what it's
like if you're a normal finisher and and
but you don't go you don't commit crimes
or make people feel like they can save
yeah yeah yeah it's like oh you just go
buy lingerie like there's cross-dressing
guy
that like to wear lingerie they jack off
or whatever totally fine or if you like
you gotta steal it from BB yeah or if
you'd like to tell your girlfriend like
hey this is a really weird thing that I
like to do and then you and your
girlfriend yeah that's cool that's cool
but it's like don't do this though they
want a [ __ ] collector smell it later
oh my god that's [ __ ] rapey dude I
like your use of props and I was really
I was really nice thank you
well I guess you'd be better the ones
that they actually contact the girls and
would be like hey I'll pay for your
underwear that's creepy but a little bit
less nothing that's very honor what the
girl should have done though they should
have got together and been like yo let's
give this [ __ ] the ugliest
[ __ ] [ __ ] that are [ __ ] our body
can produce it might like it and leave
that let's play why why it wants to get
marks and stuff there are some
disgusting guys out there what they
should have done is actually they should
corner him and like gagged him all the
way and like made him show and actually
he wouldn't like that too you can't love
to be a hot [ __ ] and I get those
inquiries on my Instagram is like listen
I'll give you 500 bucks if you spit in
my mouth and stomp on my face I recently
got that someone that had no profile
picture and it looked like they've just
created the account just to send me this
message they were like how much would
would you charge for some dirty panties
I got the same one are you serious yeah
how much how much yeah dude ten thousand
dollars charge yeah can I be your agent
you see you're sitting on a gold mine I
don't even have to be yours you could
cuz you guys got it I'll start an agency
and manage both of you guys
you get your the ones that you brought
to throw away anyway have Casey wipe his
ass with it and then [ __ ] two plane
tickets to like Cabo or something shoot
not even toxic a feeling like what do
you say what'd he say I'm like huh how
real do you think this is whatever it's
just like a fan just know it's real it's
happens one of our guy friends Oh true
and that's pretty real no no I was like
I'm just saying like what's what's the
issue because number one they're not
touching you yep they're not like even
like they made contact selfish is [ __ ]
that's what so don't you want more money
you don't care about your child house
money and selfish have any because you
can just spend it on yourself yep it's
just better child you know I just like
what's mine and what's mine is mine is
mine is mine that's why I like you way
more than I like her dude hey can I have
your boogers for $10,000 [ __ ] yeah
too much self-respect
that's not self-respect self-respect is
when you're willing to give what yep
yeah you respect yourself you know your
own value in this world know your own
value yeah easy do you know what you do
just name a prices to see if they
receive if you want one of gos penny
where's it's gonna cost you 30 G's no
starting okay that's the starting price
and that's not even the cute ones either
that's like the throwaway [ __ ]
you want the good [ __ ] my dude come talk
to Barb take care of you I'm sure she
could handle her own business and crazy
nah she's too selfish like that no no
you need to create that professional
distance
remain untouchable now offer by the way
thirty thousand dollars and needs to be
directed positive first yeah yeah cuz we
don't lie we're the honest people yeah
you're the weird one that's exactly do
you [ __ ] freak
if you guys want my dirty boxers three
dollars people if you want me to [ __ ] in
a jar and send it over VI a UPS PS or
UPS or FedEx UPS you fee at PS oh [ __ ] I
kind of wish you would have thrown out a
number first and I would have been like
$10,000 yes so many do nothing the
problem no once this comes out though
now people are just gonna troll you that
first one when you guys didn't talk
about it that would be serious we've
talked about you have talked about it oh
okay you better put out some real
[ __ ] offers just venmo half the money
first and then we won't take you
seriously so the money's in the bank
[Applause]
you
you